is there something
um deeper to be said about our trust and
institutions
and governments and so on that has to do
with ufos
that there there's a kind of suspicion
that the us
government and governments in general
are hiding stuff from us uh
when you talk about ufos this is my view
on that if we declassified everything
i think we would find a lot more
evidence all pointing toward the same
puzzle
there aren't some alien men being held
underground yes there's not some secret
file that lays out whatever is happening
i think the real lesson about government
is government cannot
bring itself to any new belief on this
matter
of any kind and it's a kind of funny
inertia like government is deeply
puzzled
they're more puzzled than they want to
admit to us which like
i i'm okay with that actually they
shouldn't just be out panicking people
in the streets
but at the end of the day it's a bit
like approving the astrazeneca vaccine
yeah like which does work and they
haven't approved it like when are they
going to do it like when is
our government actually if only
internally
going to take this more than just
seriously but like take it truly
seriously yeah
and i just don't know if we have that
capability kind of mentally
to sound like eric weinstein for another
[Laughter]
moment
you